a woman claims she was shot or who shot
her boyfriend
by accident but police are saying that
there's a lot more to the story 24 year
old
mary catherine higdon told officers she
accidentally shot her 23 year old
boyfriend stephen freeman two years ago
there were high school sweethearts but
higdon's murder trial revealed their
relationship had grown toxic
david begneau spoke exclusively with
higdon for tonight's 48 hours
suspicion it's august 1st 2018
i get a call from one of my
investigators so we had a shooting
victim on sunnybrook drive and it didn't
look good
stone county 9-1-1
in the night i'm so sorry when
lieutenant chris wilson arrived at the
scene
he found mary katherine higdon frantic
as first responders tried to save the
life of her boyfriend
stephen freeman steven died
mary catherine told police that her gun
went off accidentally
as she was handing it to steven who had
been sitting on a mattress in their
living room
none of our guns that we've had around
our house were ever
you know chambered there was never a
bullet in the chamber it was never my
intention to
ever injure him
or kill him the police were suspicious
like a big fighter here
and mary katherine's story about the gun
seemed unlikely
to detective adam trammell is it
possible for this gun to just
go off accidentally not from my
experience the trigger would have to be
pulled
mary catherine was taken in for
questioning police didn't believe her
and after confronting her they say she
confessed
she said i did it out of anger
yeah just like that thinking they had
the confession on tape mary catherine
was arrested
but there was a big problem with the
recording
we can't hear it but prosecutor kate
leonard says they had plenty of other
evidence
the state contended the couple's
relationship was unraveling
and mary catherine shot stephen in anger
after he hadn't come home for dinner and
ignored her calls and text messages
at trial mary katherine claimed she was
the victim
of an abusive boyfriend he smacked me
around sometimes
he would grab me and shake me and she
says steven had raped her
on two occasions and that's why she was
afraid of him
the night she shot him she had never
told
anyone that before and he can't defend
himself
mary catherine insists she was
embarrassed to tell the police that
stephen had a history of violence toward
her
what would a jury believe
wow and david begneau joins us now david
i want to talk about that uh
alleged confession tape uh police say it
happened but the tape apparently went
blank
what happened to that tape and how did
it affect the outcome of the case
tony it's like the one question i kept
having leading up to that interview with
the investigators how is it possible
that you guys
did this and it was like listen we
didn't mean to there was feedback on the
tape we don't know what happened
there's a lot of questions we then asked
them like well did you try again did you
go back when did you realize that you
had feedback on the tape
but the bottom line is that could have
been that could have been the number one
key thing the prosecution needed at the
trial
so without it what ended up happening
and how did it influence the verdict
you'll hear tonight prime time
10 o'clock 9 central all right looking
forward to it david thank you very much
and as david mentioned you can watch us
report the case against mary catherine
higdon
on 48 hours suspicion tonight at 10 9
central here on cbs